you were of course during the election
Labour's campaigns and elections
chairman you remain that the national
election coordinator so you'll certainly
have a view on this while there is
jagged or modest still an MP well of
course there's now an investigation and
I think it's right that he's been
suspended from the Labour Party and that
due process will now take place where
obviously the very serious concerns that
have been raised rightly about some of
the tweets that he's posted in the past
will be fully investigated and it's
right that we root out any misogyny
sexism homophobia and racism in the
labour party which we should they'll
consider the chronology of events yet an
investigation is now underway but
despite a party spokesman saying that
the first they'd heard of this was was
just days ago actually we know nor
labour HQ knew about this you know back
in September you were made aware of the
the earliest comments that he made about
poofters and fudge-packers of all things
about Jamie Cullum being sodomized by
his own piano
you and mr. O'Mara did nothing until the
reports were made public why not well I
didn't know about these things and I
found those comments absolutely
despicable and let me make it absolutely
clear there is no place in the Labour
Party for homophobia for sexism for
misogyny and for racism and this often
didn't think that they were absolutely
reprehensible
you know mr. lamagno it wasn't a child
when he made these comments he wasn't a
teenager he was an adult now who despite
making comments which as you concede are
homophobic in the extreme at the meeting
of the peop at which mr. Oman has stood
up and apologised mr. carbon then stood
up said we should accept that apology
and you know what hold on to that seat
on a lot of things the equalities
committee no I'm not sure that that is
actually the case I think what you will
find is that Jeremy Corbyn has called
out misogyny and sexism and racism and
he's not said that we should accept that
apology for mr. Romana and that he
should continue on the equalities commit
Jared Amara has been suspended from the
Labour Party that is the right course of
action and there is an investigation I
don't want to prejudice but nevertheless
those views are reprehensible and they
have no place in a modern day
see I'm just trying to work out what
what actually changed within within the
party hierarchy those comments made in
2002 and 2004 which seem to have been
dismissed because he was a bit younger
when he made them and he's been on it
but a journey of all things since then
but in 2009 five years after he first
stood for the Labour Party he was
referring online to a rhythm section
tighter than your mother's ex a band
better than fellatio from Angelina Jolie
now that was enough to suspend him but
comments about fudge crackers and poof
does that that's okay look it's all
disgusting and I think we've let the
investigation take place and we let you
process happen the problem is this let
me put a proposition to you or anyone of
course can become a member of parliament
if they get enough votes not everyone
should be a member of parliament mr.
lamagno may not be a sexist a homophobe
a racist and it's clearly an idiot and
as part of the investigation we need to
look at how the procedures for selection
and the choice of mr. O'Mara were
adhered to by the party that is part of
the investigation because nobody holding
those views in my view has a place in
modern democracy
it's just I'm struggling to understand
my comments that were made slightly
earlier in the first decade of this
millennium you know were considered to
be less extreme than comments made
towards the tail-end he was in his 20s
throughout that process and it's
insulting isn't it so people of that age
to suggest like it's the type of thing
you see when you're young well I didn't
say those things we were designed and I
find them reprehensible there's no
excuse for those those comments and I
think that we let the investigation take
due process I mean it's a problem that
we within the party that you you don't
necessarily have enough oversight of the
process by which someone like mr. Romana
pushed forward by momentum you know
ultimately ends up taking a seat in the
husband he did sign that document didn't
he that said there is nothing in my past
that can bring the party into disrepute
I mean when the first comments came to
like he should have been suspended at
that point shouldn't he well I'm not
sure what the process was when those
first comments did come to light that's
not something that I've been made aware
of but I think it's absolutely right
that the Labour Party has suspended him
pending an investigation now let that
investigation happen just in terms of
the procedures that were within the
party I mean mr. Corbyn has said that
there has to be a proper system of
people being able to report if they feel
abused our party the Labour Party has a
process for doing that for party members
who feel they've been abused in any way
I mean do you think that the procedures
are robust enough and I think they are
if they're used correctly and I think
that where people feel that they have
been abused that they should have the
confidence to come through the party
processes that are in place to make
their views known and let the party deal
with it if there needs to be changes to
the party rules then that's something
that a Labour conference in the future
will consider the National Executive
Committee will consider
but the point is there are processes and
there are rules in place to prevent this
kind of thing I'm going I'm going to
submit that the procedures that are in
place are not up to or not up to scratch
I may take this an anonymous female
labour councillor you know writing in
The Guardian I mean she said I'm ashamed
of the way the Labour Party currently
handles some cases of harassment some
abuse and assault brought to them by its
members in my experience of reporting
such behaviour to the party I have felt
completely let down my complaint was
swept under the carpet and the
perpetrators continued to play a part in
my everyday life within the party no
complaint should be swept under the
carpet what are you well very well I
think we need to look very carefully if
this is the kind of thing that is
happening if people are saying that this
is happening then perhaps the National
Executive Committee need to look at well
you've given one anonymous quote or she
went what she went on to repeat a story
a number of times to a number of
different people within the party she
said that there's no way under the
current rules that you can link your
connecting patterns or behavior of
experiences of different women to a
single perpetrator I mean these are
party members making this complaint and
it's on top of a litany of complaints
that have been made about the internal
party procedures within labour well then
you know we have to
look at making sure that members have
the confidence in the rules and the
procedures that are in place to deal
with these situations and I don't want
any member of the Labour Party whether
they are a card-carrying member an
activist a counselor or a member of
parliament to feel that there is one
rule for one set of members and another
rule for others we are all one family in
the labour party and we adhere to those
rules and that we adhere to the
expectations you know we are a
democratic party but there is no place
for misogyny for racism for sexism and
for homophobia all of those things as
we've just mentioned currently exist
within the Labour Party I think the
problem for mr. Corbin is I'll submit
this you know we've been talking about
abuse of power and a variety of forms
you know for decades you know child
sexual abuse the abuse of women within
the workplace it's nothing new mr.
Carvin has identified this what culture
that pervades Westminster
it hasn't suddenly emerged overnight but
it's taken action in Hollywood and you
know the actions of one labor at we are
recent appointees MP for the Labour
Party to even start talking about it not
even do anything about it we start
talking about it and of course this
isn't just an issue for the Labour Party
it's an issue for politics
I will see as we see from wells bad you
know and it is a plague on all our
houses and we have to make sure that
certainly Parliament if we are making
the laws against some of these things we
need to make sure that we ourselves up
hold those laws and those standards and
I am quite frankly appalled by some of
the stories that I've read today you and
me both and let's say dwell for a second
are on on your brief and local
government and a real focus for you
moving forward as its children's cream
and you love the opinion that we are
we're heading into crisis will be
talking mental health as regards
children in a while establish your
position well of course a lot of the
concerns that there have been about
local government finance in recent years
has been looking at the problems of
adult social care and the government
have over the past few years
brought forward a number of sticking
plasters to try and ease the council's
problems and so what we are now seeing
in a lot of councils is the problem
surfacing in Children Services
children's services are underfunded by
about two billion pounds across the
whole of England and that is causing
real problems because of course these
are statutory services the council if
they are presented with safeguarding
issues they have to take on board those
issues and they have to deal with them
it's not something that can be put aside
a budget column and to say well we've
reached that budget they have to take it
doesn't all in essence come down to
funding the one we're talking about the
provision well it comes in to funding
but it also comes into the wider sphere
of public policy because many of the
reasons that children are being brought
into the Children's Services sphere is
because of the cuts elsewhere so things
like cuts to shore start have been a
very short-sighted cut and it's meant
that children and families are suffering
elsewhere I just want once we have you
just to dwell in on brexit there has
been something of a difficulty on the
government benches this week about
whether or not you know you will get a
vote at an appropriate point if there is
to be a vote of of consequence in the
House of Commons it needs to happen
before we leave the European Union
doesn't it it absolutely doesn't it
needs to happen before the European
Parliament have a vote on it as well you
know we didn't vote to take back control
only to cede parliamentary sovereignty
to ministers we absolutely have to have
that vote before both the European
Parliament and before brexit happen is
there any way though by which you can
compel that well I think through our
amendments in the the repeal bill reking
amendment well they're not wrecking
amendments this is about Parliament
taking back control if we believe in
parliamentary sovereignty it means that
MPs have got to have the guts to say
this is what we want and if we want to
vote to ensure that our constituents are
protected you know you don't jump out of
a plane without a parachute so we want
to make sure that we've got that
parachute strapped on and that's what
having that final vote before the
European Parliament and before
we leave the European Union in March
2019 happens